remember this puny
humans we came here for justice not
murder so no one on your planet has died
by our hands and no one
will but we'll make sure no one on earth
will ever forget what you
are
liars
traitors and
Killers now will raise this city to the
ground and leave you to your shame no we
tried to explain again and again but you
wouldn't listen so this this is your
last chance to surrender or
what hello old
[Music]
friend
you don't want this fight
Cent
yes God help me I do because you're the
only one I can
hit like
this all
right
Stark
Richards
all of
you never
forget whatever happens next is on your
heads
good just
once
more that's
it stupid humans you think your machines
can stop
him Bruce you have to tell me something
does it always feel this good when you
finally let
go I tried to calm you down
and now at the end of it
all it's
me you can't seem to
stop
Goodbye old friend now to we still
hacking the databases have it measured
the effects of the combined Rays so
narrow the scope in the fire call the
containment teams but we've got to hit
them now stupid they can call you
whatever they want savior
Destroyer all that matters is what you
[Music]
choose n
Bruce
[Music]
thanks look upon him
within each of us live The worldbreaker
Who destroys all and the
Saron who redeems the world today
finally the Hulk knows who he is
Bruce welcome
home you're not done
yet come back
Rick
Bruce no
Bruce